già tutti allora veglia de lise già
presente in altri deo mia amica oggi
facciamo un gioco un po strano lo spiego
chiama geox praticamente come funziona
funziona cioè noi veniamo catapultati in
una parte del mondo completamente a caso
e dove mentre le siamo io so che tu sei
brava in geografia solo questa è roma
parlata bene perché non è facile del dna
sco veramente bene allora il primo
venezia è andata veramente bene ragazzi
non è sempre così immagino di no devi
andare proprio a cliccare esattamente
sul punto tra l'altro in venezia ma
calle della madonna come lo voleva
chiamare per chef non sappiamo dove
calle la madonna quindi non ci voglia di
cercarlo davvero quindi andiamo lui
cagliari la madonna non è lì a un
chilometro profani e questa non e
venezia per farti un altro esempio
firenze era chiaro
mettiamo la situazione non so dove
chicago un dispenser di bacini non
gliene frega proprio niente non smette
un secondo te li dove siamo noi siamo ha
detto non è los angeles con un primate
di chicago chicago dallo scalo qua qua a
little village madonna proprio lui è un
genio un genio
eugenio eugenio 5 km quasi vicino come a
venezia madonna ci sono stati mai ci ha
configurati a questo è un boss del clan
ok basilica di nostra signora di grease
che sta a parigi marie parigi dove cazzo
affari nico basilica di nostra signora
cate danno tra dando poi tutto va bene
sono perso roberto eccola qua eccola qua
cacchio e allora mettiamo che siamo qui
[Musica]
c'è una curva ma come erano affatto il
posto siamo stupidi effettivamente
perché giocare
vabbè dai 316 metri ei sono quelli di
giochi ester ma a me visto qualcosa è
successo qui in spagna più padre che mi
dovrebbe essere un po scomodo per a
saragozza sarà cose che sarà
quindi metto corsa sarà cosa tutti
insieme il kaki nella basilica di nostra
signora ci sarà mai ancora questa questa
notte è stata questa
[Musica]
e giusto qui bravo centro capitale gay o
bisex che non lo dire non me lo dire non
me lo dire non me lo dire
amanda si chiama allora siamo sul
titanic
facciamo di aiutare il fabrizio che lì
perché riesce a vedere la statua della
libertà minuscola fabrizio allora
immagino sia a new york o anche visitata
lista non mi ricordo verità li secco la
mamma mia
allora statua rivolta verso qua ma ellis
island si no non è lì syle alberi che
sono stupide cura di pianico è stato
divertente stato sta qua no parolario
ciechi top stato effettivamente dove c'è
scritto stato akwa qui precisa per la
parte poco bambù la pausini non ho idea
di dove sia questo però di preciso se
sarà nell'unico fumo non è vero è
talmente conosciuto che noi quindi è
questo quindi è qua
sydney opera house 13 metri buona noli
se ti stesi per terra
sei volte ci si arriva perfetto ma il
presupposto hai detto siamo la fiducia
guarda che buono è casa mia
no si no
sia la casa bianca si sia libero che ci
sono fuori io sono quasi sicuro che
avevano sbagliato però sbagliato tutto
da allora è sempre washington ma non
c'entra non ha senso come canada giusto
della conformazione degli alberi che io
a loro
raga canada fila il grosso però il
cantone forte layard e corretto l'annata
anni national park reserve sai che si
celano tardi bicchia per un attimo per
potervi generare wyoming gara del guaio
abbiamo azzeccato il continente ma non è
vero io mi non è in canada continente al
continente scusa
ora sto bene qua labour qua tutto da un
po siamo dentro un edificio io so dove
siamo non sono mai stato mai 40 che ti
ricordi il film quell'ora andavano 007
no che c'è stata quella come si chiama
pratica che farai film catherine zeta
jones che doveva fa c'era del capodanno
dovranno fare i dischi i soldi è
passavano detto stavolta con un posto
non ricordo di 40 bye bye bye di quello
hai visto che mentre mio cane se c'è un
patrimonio a questa memoria di word di
lincoln lincoln memorial dove abbiamo
agito vai noli po più avanti
no qui allora questo è bello la strada
considerarlo il conte idraulico ragazzi
nessuno mi sta guardando mentre car
governo no limits on news su woodstock
non mannstein in germania meno male
dov'è che stava frankestein acquatico
qua oberhausen ha 61 km scorsi news vi
ebbe certo mia seconda scelta e
chiacchiere banca sto vedendo bay marca
dai sono all'asta di leggo c'è una città
dei lego in danimarca
ho capito ma hanno fatto una città
dell'ego in dei lego in danimarca
odense copenaghen la città dei lego la
famosissima città dei lego che tutti
abbiamo già visto no proprio quella che
si chiama the u na lil
[Musica]
pagliari barca dove a billund legoland
c'è solo quelli qualità ah sì sì ci
siamo andati ricordi ha senso anche dove
non avevamo per trafalgar square e uno
zoom che prova buongiorno nuovissimo
l'ultimo dall'ultimo e basta
l'ultimo facciamo la sola europa perché
questo non è accaduto però attenzione
non sono questi famosi e credo che sia
un po di teste calde tipo questa è
chiaramente vienna dal mostra questo
fanno praticamente le statue dei dalmata
e trovarsi adesso dice scritto hr sulla
macchina ao che veramente si ma facciamo
i posti comodi vi prego fece uguale
sgancia il berlino siano in polonia si è
accesa me ma tutto è possibile pagare è
una mappa in testa ma come mai come
capisci il polacco quasi certo questa è
una ciste cosa ma tu come strumento di
questo tipo lacco ameno dove la polacca
ciste sarà qua qua ci sta minkia 900
metri non è male è bravissimo a
posteriori 8 questa in inghilterra ma
non sappiamo dove potrebbe anche in
serie b perché non parte che sono le
capitali però proprio che il marito
adrian e l'inghilterra e la germania
siamo a berlino non saper niente di
berlino abbatteremo solo messo capelli
lunghi che cacchio vista lì per lì non
ho come è vero che non sanno niente di
berlino però non è
inglese ma perché per i non hanno il
manubrio non lo so dovrebbe può andar
l'aiuto congo dove che altro era un'idea
ragazzi ma quella o così all sos tram
normal non sarà una città normale
qui vediamo qua io avrei detto
copenhagen perché mi sembrava troppo
danimarca patisserie le banche uno dei
giorni scorsi a questo
vabbè parigi tra parigi qui buono le km
buonissimo mongo db database dei mongoli
di cazzi stata mondo di b io ho affidato
a dublino a far mito come è stato a
dublino ma che cazzo dici ma veramente è
vero ma chi sei ma lo dicono appunto in
irlanda e tre da strill.it è stata la
mia rovina perché il sito per cercare le
case vi volevo morire 100 milioni dal
terzo piano tube
ragazzi basta adesso l'abbiamo dato ma
io ho avuto questo tutto il tempo
gli ho detto questi da giorni ciao però
divide vi sia piaciuto mettete mi piace
e fatemi sapere sono ad altri episodi e
vi mando un bacio gigante a distanza
[Musica]